thank you and please man I'm very
honored to be here and you all look
swell and that's the end of my speech
now can you flip them over for me
because I didn't say what I was supposed
to the five gentlemen tonight were
nominated for the best performance by an
actor have earned that honor by
following all the rules that all the
great actors of all times have tried to
do and tonight is just another splendid
night they are mr. Peter Finch in Sunday
Bloody Sunday a Joseph Janney production
United Artists gene Hackman in the
French Connection D'Antoni productions
20th Century Fox Walter Matthau in Koch
a Koch company production ABC Pictures
presentation Cinerama George see Scott
in the hospital a Howard Godfried paddy
Chayefsky production in association with
Arthur Hiller United Artists Topo in
Fiddler on the Roof Amira Scotty a
production United Artists hmm you have
the envelope well you guys is nervous at
all and the winner is the winner is mr.
gene
thank you very much
I just want to start at the beginning
just for a second and say sitting out
there next to Barbara house reminds me
of my first acting scene ever was in New
York and the gentleman sitting in front
of us when we were doing that scene was
my acting teacher and I just have to
mention his name George Morris and I
want to thank him also mr. Billy
freaking who has already received his
prize a night but I have to thank him
because he he really brought me through
this when I wanted to quit and eddie
egan you all know mr. phil D'Antoni Roy
Scheider Roy and last a young lady who I
met in New York many years ago Miss
Philippa multi C and she brought me up
to